[Musique]
tout va bien
montréal la métropole comme tout le
québec des années 60 nage en pleine
révolution tranquille en 1963 les bombes
annonce la naissance d'un mouvement
séparatiste clandestins et radicale le
front de libération du québec des
attentats du flq feront 16 victimes
entre avril 63 et septembre 70 le
vainqueur cette année là en 1970 les
libéraux de robert bourassa sont portés
au pouvoir le parti québécois récolte
près du quart des votes mais n'obtient
que 7 sièges un résultat
inacceptable pour le flq c'est ici que
débute la crise d'octobre de sa demeure
par quatre armées à 8h20 le 5 octobre
quatre membres du flq kidnappe james
richard cross l'attaché commercial du
haut commissariat de la grande bretagne
il pose des conditions à sa libération
je puis dire que l'on réclame la
publication d'un manifeste politique
dans tous les journaux du québec
on réclame la libération de centaines de
prisonniers politiques
les déserts pour les domaines
le flq insiste sur la diffusion de son
manifeste il sera lu à la radio et
finalement sur les ondes de radio canada
le soir du 8 octobre le front de
libération du québec de l'indépendance
totale des québécois réunis dans une
société libre pour ses auteurs les
canadiens français seront exploités par
les grandes entreprises et leurs
propriétaires anglophone par les
gouvernements et l'église catholique
deux jours plus tard samedi 10 octobre
le ministre de la justice jérôme
choquette refuse toujours de libérer les
prisonniers dits politiques mais il
vient offrir une voie de sortie pour
ravisseurs à titre de concession ultime
pour sauver la vie de monsieur cross le
gouvernement fédéral mais forme qu'il
est disposé à vous offrir le sauf
conduit vers un pays étranger
trop peu trop tard le flq passe à
l'action
une nouvelle fois de seconde série du
flq la cellule chénier enlève le
ministre québécois du travail des
migrations monsieur pierre laporte la
crise d'octobre prend une tournure
encore plus dramatique ce soir là pierre
laporte est kidnappé alors qu'il jouait
avec son neveu devant chez lui à saint
lambert
bientôt l'armée se déploie dans la
capitale fédérale
des soldats entoure les ambassades et
les édifices gouvernementaux d'ottawa
une présence qui dérange
un journaliste de la bbc confronte
pierre elliott trudeau à ce sujet
le soir du 15 octobre au centre paul
sauvé de montréal une assemblée réuni
3000 personnes des étudiants et des
séparatistes solidaire du flq
on va s'organiser et d'anyama on va
choisir d'autres
[Musique]
cette nuit là à la demande de montréal
et du gouvernement du québec ottawa
proclame la loi sur les mesures de
guerre pour la première fois en temps de
paix dès 4 heures du matin le 16 octobre
près de 500 personnes sont arrêtées
leurs droits sont suspendus quand je me
suis dit est-ce que vous avez la loi
pierre dans le tumulte des journalistes
de la radio s'est cassé reçoivent un
message du flq
dans ce message il est indiqué que l'on
retrouverait le cadavre de pierre d'un
corps dans une automobile ou chevronnés
l'automobile est à l'endroit indiqué
près de l'aéroport de saint-hubert le 17
octobre la police ouvre le coffre et il
trouve le corps de pierre laporte rouge
du décès asphyxie aiguë par
strangulation olliet le lien était de
toute vraisemblance sa chaînette de
coups qu'il faut tout un corps pur
moment de la taxi
près d'une centaine de membres de
l'assemblée nationale assistent aux
funérailles de pierre laporte quelques
jours plus tard à la basilique notre
dame de montréal ministre le plus
expérimenté du cabinet bourassa il avait
failli devenir premier ministre
il est mort à 49 ans ce qui froidement
et délibérément exécutées monsieur
laporte après l'avoir vu vivre et espéré
pendant tant de jours sont des être
inhumains
il faudra des semaines pour que james
yurichuk crasse séquestrée dans cet
appartement soit finalement libéré tel
que négocié ceux qui l'ont enlevé
s'envole pour cuba avec leurs familles
le 3 décembre
en cette fin d'année 1970 au matin du 28
décembre dans une maison de saint luc en
montérégie
la police arrête finalement les
ravisseurs de pierre laporte paul rose
jacques rose et français simard seront
condamnés à de lourdes peines de prison
la crise d'octobre fait partie de notre
parcours de notre histoire
elle est aussi l'un de nos grands
traumatismes collectifs